Sometimes a good mystery can be satisfying
even without a solution, but when it comes
to TV, fans tend to prefer their questions
answered, and loose ends tied up. But not
every TV show gets the time needed to tell
the story the creators intended, since networks
care more about ratings than leaving their
fans scrambling from unresolved cliffhangers
or random twists with no explanation. Here
are Screen Rant’s 10 TV Plot Holes That
Will Never Be Answered.
The Walking Dead
The first season of the The Walking Dead had
its cast of survivors looking for an explanation
for the zombie outbreak, and possibly a cure.
They eventually learned what readers of the
comic already knew: the zombie infection is
carried by every human, living or dead. In
other words, no matter how a person dies,
they're already a zombie just waiting to be
born. Creator Robert Kirkman has no intention
of explaining where the pathogen came from,
but fans shouldn't bother even trying to explain
how itworks. Despite the show's attempts
at using real science to describe the infection,
bodies that can move without bloodflow or
organs are already impossible. To make things
worse, the comic series has implied zombie
bodies decay like real flesh, which means
nearly all should be liquid after a month
or two, and skeletons after a year. Let’s
just hope that Fear The Walking Dead will
answer this mythical question!
FlashForward
When ABC's Lost was coming to an end, the
network was looking for a new sci-fi phenomenon
to take its place. And when FlashForward began,
it seemed they had found it. The premise hooked
audiences immediately, when every person on
Earth blacked out for 137 seconds, and saw
a vision of themselves six months in the future.
The show debuted to huge ratings, but the
20 episodes that followed saw the audience
fall by more than half. ABC cancelled plans
for a second season, but only after the finale
had been filmed, leaving characters' lives
in danger, and another blackout showing different
visions even farther ahead. The cliffhanger
was all fans got, with only their imagination
to offer any real ending.
Game of Thrones
The fantasy series deals mainly with the politics
of noble men and women, but from the very
start, it was the mysterious White Walkers
who stole the show. The blue-eyed creatures
have faded into legend by the time the series
begins, having remained hidden for over 8,000
years, but the massive Wall built to keep
them in the North shows they were once the
greatest threat ever seen. The creatures appear
as frozen zombies in the TV series, but author
George R. R. Martin describes the White Walkers,
or "Others" differently: in the novels, they
are beautiful beings who speak an ancient
tongue, craft impossible weapons, and are
nearly unstoppable in every way. In other
words: TV audiences hoping to see their origins
or motivations explained shouldn't hold their
breath. No one is left alive who remembers,
anyway.
Lost
It’s no secret that ABC’s Lost raised
more questions than it did answers, with some
of the strangest twists or mysteries in the
series left completely unresolved by the time
the series ended. Much was made of Hurley’s
connection to the Numbers, 4,8,15,16,23,42
– used in the Swan station, blown wide open
in the season 1 finale. But the horrible run
of bad luck that they brought Hurley, referred
to as “a curse” by the man who first uncovered
them, is never explained. Was it a curse,
or all in his head? But one of the most debated
questions is one the writers simply refuse
to solve. When season 5 saw Sawyer and Juliet’s
group exchange gunfire with another boat,
fans expected to find out who the unknown
men actually were. No answer ever came, and
the most obvious assumptions were thrown out
when the showrunners claimed it was a closely-guarded
secret. DVD extras hinted that it may have
been the time-travelling crew of the 19th
century ship stranded on the island, but until
the writers spill
the beans, fans only have theories to debate.
Awake
Not every TV show can win over critics on
its premise alone, but even with star Jason
Isaacs, it was the fractured format of NBC’s
Awake that hooked early viewers. After a car
accident leaves Detective Michael Britten’s
son dead, he and his wife attempt to rebuild
their shattered home life. Until Michael goes
to sleep, and wakes up in a world where it
was his wife who died in the car accident
instead. Unsure of which reality was the “real”
one, he realizes that details from a current
case in each reality help him solve the mystery
in the other. Despite the reality-bending
hook and solid cast, Awake was cancelled during
its first season, meaning the writers had
time to adjust their finale, showing Michael,
his wife and son all reunited. But it’s
not an answer to the core question of the
show: Creator Kyle Killen said the original
ending couldn’t work in so short a time,
meaning the finale is just further fracturing
of Michael’s mind – not a happy ending.
So what do you think of our list? Did we miss
any unsolved TV show mysteries that still
drive you crazy? Let us know in our comment
section and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for more videos like this one.